hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
i'm here to go through jimmy price
action last week we broke out god from
guys from the triangle but not on the
upside it wasn't the downside we went
almost close to 87 we are now very close
to this 87 level that is a very very
important level and in this video guys i
will show you the two different
scenarios if we stay above what could
happen and if we break out below this
level what could happen let's get into
it
[Music]
all right guys i'm on the daily
timeframe i'm on gme and
guys it's not easy i analyzed that quite
deeply today and i'm here to give you
the truth guys to give you my view
once again i know that a lot of you are
telling me yeah you were talking about
some crazy levels you were wrong all
right guys that's true that's totally
true uh i got trapped here i'm always
repeating it and i'm happy to get
trapped again all right jamie amc it's
some very difficult place
that's why
playing it with only buying shares to me
is not the right thing to do this is not
what i'm doing this is not what i've
been doing in my discord you guys know
that i was here in gme and that in the
end i made money alright so what i want
to show you guys here is that depending
on what is happening there is always a
plan b that you need to be prepared for
and that you need to adapt i'm going to
show you here in this video i'm here
having shares of jimmy i'm having shares
i'm short called so i'm having some
covered call and i think i will do
something else guys on monday because uh
the situation is not looking so good to
me so first let's analyze the situation
in my last video guys i was saying that
gme can blow up of course it was in both
directions i was bullish guys uh totally
true i hear
you know just the the mark the bears
were too strong right we had this
bullish signal we had this bullish
signal here a bullish engulfing so this
is a breakout this is a stop hunting you
can see here bass got trapped booze got
it back inside the triangle this is
usually bullish this gave us as well a
bullish engulfing as you can see this
candle engulfed completely the one
before it was not enough guys as you can
see we had uh some resistance around the
50-day moving average that was also
creating this triangle
upper band decreasing triangle upper
band
and i was really expecting
an upside breakout guys and this was the
point of my video and i said that this
is my preferred scenario and if it
happens we'll probably fly 260 then get
rejected and then see what happens
i also told you guys that if we break
out below this triangle lower band at
115 we will probably go to 87 right so
you can go watch this video i'm always
giving you two scenarios and this is
what happened and right now guys let's
analyze what is happening here i don't
like what i'm seeing okay i hope i'm
gonna be wrong
because what i'm gonna show you guys
here is not a bullish view unfortunately
first break out below the triangle as i
said uh in my discord where i post daily
analysis by the way sorry guys i didn't
post for the past two three days because
i'm quite busy on many things
it was not an increasing volume so for
this reason when we have a breakout that
is not an increasing volume it can be a
fake out the next day we opened very
close to the triangle lower band and
then we had this brutal move down on
higher volume all right so it was not
easy to play that
uh for those who have shares to you know
exit if you want or to buy some puts you
know to get protection it was not easy
to trade all right that's true i
personally didn't do anything i lost
money here on the way down
but i made money on the global market
will have a decent short position but
whatever okay let's finish analyzing the
situation so increasing volume on the
way down and we are coming back close to
the 87 support level that is a very
important level guys that i'm giving you
for a very long time 87 is my level for
i don't know for how long but i guess a
few months
even maybe more guys i don't really
remember uh because it was here guys all
right and as you can see what i'm going
to tell you guys is a bit scary but
you're going to see where i want to
bring you
87 holds all right it hold pretty well
sorry 87 is here by the way because it's
the low
level it's the low we had here on feb
25th all right guys then it has been
tested once twice only so it's still a
strong level
but this time we arrive here guys on
increasing volume
okay it's never good when you see a move
is happening on increasing volume it
usually means we're in the middle of
something right not at the end of it
whenever the volume decreases we're
usually at the end of something just
like here we were at the end actually of
this bullish move okay we couldn't know
that i thought we were at the end of
this whole move down but we are always
at the end of something when the volume
is decreasing and then something happens
and then this is the direction for the
coming
weeks days depending on what kind of
pattern you analyze so here we have
increasing volume increasing volume so
it's not a big increase but it's still
going higher so we will almost for sure
touch 87 uh guys on i don't know if it's
on monday so minus five percent monday
tuesday i don't know but this week we're
gonna probably touch this level if it
doesn't hold
guys this is where i want to bring you
because this is
i don't have here preferred scenario i'm
50 50. i hope it's gonna hold uh once
again i have shares
uh i'm short calls so i have some
protection but not a lot of protection
and downside and
guys look what happened each time we
went from 37 to 87 all right so i know
it's 50 points
but look it happened twice uh three
times first time it was in gen 21 okay
we have this consolidation around 37.
let's put it here around 40 let's call
it 40
40 level okay consolidation just below
40. and then pam massive move up in two
days we go from 40 to 87.
then second time
in
one day we go from 87
to 55 and then
slowly decreased to 37 but once again
brutal move and last time we went from
40 to 87 in one time so what i'm showing
you guys here is that
whenever we enter this area
we
in the past did it three times the three
times we had
massive massive moves what does it mean
it means that there is no support or
resistance level in here it's like a no
man's land the price action doesn't stay
inside this area it goes from one side
to the other side
so
it's very hard to trade of course
because uh whenever it starts to happen
it goes very fast as you can see for
example here the last time it happened
it was on feb third
we opened above we opened at 90 and in
one day we went here so i'm not saying
it's gonna happen
i'm just saying that if it happens it's
very hard to trade so i'm gonna show you
what i will do probably
uh to be protected about that because
this is a very brutal move down and then
probably if this happens
uh we're gonna have a massive buddhist
reaction so once again this is not my
preferred tonight it's just one scenario
that is absolutely scary guys and i need
to tell you because there is something
you can still do if you don't want to be
in that okay even if it happens not
doing anything is fine because we'll
probably have a strong rebound coming so
if you just close your eyes wait a week
or two
hopefully not but maybe we would go from
240 and then back to 87. let's see but
if you don't want to close your eyes you
want to watch the market and you want to
try to protect yourself and even maybe
make some money
uh you have march 18th uh 80 put you
guys okay so i know you guys don't like
to sell your shares but there is nothing
wrong about buying a put right about
buying some protection this protection
is very expensive guys it costs at spot
two dollars to get a march 18th or five
days put so it's extremely expensive but
there is a reason behind that it's
because market makers know what happens
in this area all right it's not only me
everybody knows what happens in this
area and this is the reason why the
price is so damn expensive
but two dollars is not that much
compared to
what happens if we go to 40 all right so
it's basically we lose 50 guys i know
it's very scary i hope it's not gonna
happen i'm just showing you this
scenario so you invest two so two
hundred dollars but you make three
thousand three hundred i'm not saying to
bet on the downside i'm saying that for
those who have shares this is a very
expensive protection but that can save
half of the investment if this scenario
happens i think i'm gonna go there the
reason why i'm gonna go there guys is
because i'm short cold so
let me show you okay i'm short call
uh june this one and so my short call
position
is actually bringing me
six dollars right
so i'm gonna cash in six dollars until
june thanks to the short call position
so i can invest a little bit in
protection i can invest six dollars i'm
gonna invest two uh for now because i
think it can happen this week and then i
still have four dollars to invest into
protection if i want to and if i don't
want it just protects my investment by
giving me some premium this is a covered
call strategy if you're interested to
know how this works come join me on
discord guys uh this is what i'm doing
so let's do the buddhist scenario and
yeah very quickly guys i'm invited to be
a speaker at a free webinar on march
16th uh subscribe to the link in the
description of this video it's going to
be very interesting i'm going to discuss
the different swing training strategies
that you can make so for those who are
interested about to know how to manage a
swing training portfolio once again guys
you know that i'm an ex professional
shadow so this is my job i know how to
do that and i'm gonna explain so it's
gonna be very interesting for the story
guys i'm invited there uh because the
ceo's assistant is the wife of my cousin
so i'm of course still an independent
trainer i'm not working for them i'm a
speaker i'm invited there and i'm
grateful for that because it's
interesting to discuss that and i hope
you guys will come come there support me
guys subscribe to this link and once
again it's everything for free of course
you're going to learn things and you're
going to be able to ask questions it's
going to be live so i hope you're going
to enjoy that and the bullish case guys
because once again this is not my
favorite scenario for those who are
going to tell me oh you were wrong again
guys don't come to me say i'm wrong all
right i'm just giving you the scenarios
so that you are prepared now
uh if we bounce at 87 because we can
bounce it hasn't only been touched twice
which is still strong so we can very
likely uh bounce from here it would
could it could even be my preferred
scenario uh you know just technically
speaking a bounce at ac at 87 makes
total sense then we'll probably be
neutral between 115 and 87 maybe
oscillate like that and same thing as
for amc guys we need to wait probably
april may for the bulls to be to take
back control in the global market uh gme
will not squeeze if we are bearish on
the global market which we are right now
guys i think we need at least one two
maybe three months
and i'm saying that for very long time
guys in deck i was saying on my discord
that would be bearish until june all
right on the global market so my view
was correct on the global market and i
think we still need some time so the
bullish case guys is not very bullish
we're gonna oscillate here that's why
selling calls makes total sense right
now you of course need to buy back your
call before uh april or may but you can
cash in a decent premium which i am
personally doing and then of course guys
here very important what's gonna happen
we're gonna have a massive uh move up a
move hopefully up guys maybe down of
course you can you need to be prepared
at the end of this triangle all right
guys so this is what uh i'm very
interested to know this is going to be
very exciting guys it's going to happen
around may so around may the market is
going to take a direction i hope it's
going to be on the upside but there is
no guarantee about that so we need to be
prepared for every scenario we're going
to analyze what is happening what is
going to happen but i can already tell
you that a low volume with the
consolidation here is probably what is
going to happen okay
i don't know what's going to happen
between but
i'm probably i'm very confident we're
going to be stuck between 87 and 115
in end of april may and then either we
go on the upside or we go on the
downside and i'm gonna be here guys to
tell you uh what hints we have what is
more likely to happen if there is any
preferred scenario and i'm going to give
you the levels for each scenario so i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did guys please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore and see you guys